hey everybody I'm Daniel Radcliffe and
I'm here to do a wired auto-complete
interview why tell us off yeah okay
what is Daniel Radcliffe favorite Harry
Potter I mean I love the last one but I
also really love the fifth which is not
a lot of people's favorite kind of
realized I love it because the
relationship of Harry and Sirius and you
get a lot of Gary Oldman in that movie
that was my favorite one probably to
film as well we had a really really good
time making that one so five or seven
part - what country is Daniel Radcliffe
from oh really
people are still asking that cool um I'm
from England there's not really much to
say that but I find it flattering that
maybe you've heard me do an American
accent and maybe that's what you thought
it wasn't British I'm gonna assume that
that that's why this question was being
asked and flattened myself in the
process what song it's a song called
alphabet aerobics by Black Alicia's I am
NOT a naturally cool person and when I
was given the opportunity to perform
that with the roots like backing me up
the whole time and you know I I was just
like well I will never get an
opportunity to do anything this cool
ever again so as nervous as it was about
it I kind of felt like I had to grab it
say alphabet aerobics the original is
better
what's Daniel house Gryffindor come on
what is Daniel Radcliffe zodiac sign I
believe I'm on the cusp of cancer and
Leo but I don't particularly believe in
it thank you
it's down there active on social media
no it's a very quick answer for you I
just know that if I were on Twitter I
would be the kind of person that gets
into fights if you are talking to
somebody on social media who is claiming
to be me feel free to go and give them I
said Iraq the Lions fan yes I actually
am this is something that amazes people
about me I am very much split loyalties
between a New York and Detroit American
sports teams my girlfriend is from Flint
I'm just outside Detroit and we are a
very big Red Wings house is Danny right
cliffs leg a lefty
no I don't think so I think I'm just
very uncoordinated with both feet
yes daniel radcliffe the new wolverine
yeah I'm like there's there's gonna be a
new Wolverine movie in which it starts
off with Hugh Jackman being put into a
hot wash and then when he comes out it's
me so yes I'm very happy to announce
that here is Daniel Radcliffe and Elijah
Wood related I mean should really be are
but ok we're not related
I have met Elijah once he came out to
the Harry Potter sir I've told also he's
been mistaken for me I am mistaken for
him very often I had a makeup artist um
one of my last jobs telling me that I
had been in a movie with Vin Diesel that
she'd sort of just seen the trailer for
yeah
away with you why is Daniel Radcliffe in
New Zealand I'm not I was last year
though a good question I was filming a
film called guns akimbo was a crazy
action movie fable weird comedy thing I
play a guy who after a series of pretty
horrible events wakes up one morning to
discover that he has been surgically
attached to a pair of guns the moment
that I knew I loved that script was
about 10 pages in where there is a scene
of him trying to go to the toilet very
very carefully with guns for hands and
that was the moment that I was like yes
good I mean I want to do this bill did
luck yeah I was very much just got lucky
and was kind of in the right place at
the right time and then fell into
something that I loved you know when
people talk about child actors and all
that stuff I think the thing that makes
me credibly lucky is that I loved what I
was doing long hair
humor talking about Frankenstein I had
hair extensions for that I recommend not
doing that if you can avoid it I've been
told I looked a little bit like a mini
Snape hope so yeah make of that what you
will
why Daniel Radcliffe wears the same
jacket every day for six months when I
was doing a play I wore the same jacket
every day because I realized that if it
looked like I was coming out of the
theatre in the same jacket in same pair
jeans every night the paparazzi looked
like they were getting photos all from
the same night when you have an
opportunity to like annoy the paparazzi
or just like win a tiny petty victory
over them that's fun
where where do does daniel radcliffe
leave now I am split between London and
New York with majority of the time in
London I'm very I'm Festa both walls go
to high school I was affiliated with a
school called City of London it was
great they were very very supportive of
me doing Potter and really helpful but
to all intents purposes I went I school
on set where is Daniel Radcliffe from
again I'm from England at the moment
part of Europe but you know where did
Daniel Radcliffe meet his girlfriend we
met only set of kill your darlings our
characters in the film meet and flirt
with each other
and the director kind of got us to
improvise and we had just met so there
is this weirdly cool sweet record of us
meeting for the first time and flirting
yes by does Daniel Radcliffe come from
the UK yes
does Daniel Radcliffe have a son no I
don't as of yet at time of recording
just Daniel Radcliffe tattoos again no
not at time of recording I really want
tattoos and I loved them on other people
but every time I think about getting one
in my head the voices of all my makeup
artists friends come into my head being
like screw you think we want to come in
half an hour earlier to cover your
tattoos before you do a topless scene
like we don't so thanks very much done
Iraq they sing yes I can carry it you I
did a Broadway musical and so I know
what it is when people can like really
sing and I'm not like that that level
but I can hold a not too challenging
tune without embarrassing myself totally
does Daniel Radcliffe like Emma Watson
yes we got on me Rupert and Emma and
all the young cast got on very very well
on the films I think there is a thing
where kind of everyone wants us to be
best friends outside of the franchise
there's always going to be a recognition
that only really the three of us have
been through that very specific thing I
think that's gonna sort of join us
forever does Daniel Radcliffe like great
see above okay and yes is the answer
obviously I love or a good two dudes
down the rock with past tense now
there's Daniel Radcliffe go to college
no I dropped out I guess is what you
would say I feel like a lot of
universities to find out what you want
to do and I very much knew what I wanted
or at least the field that I wanted to
be in for me it was thought it would be
a sideways step from what I what I
wanted to do know most of these
questions I can be like okay see where
this has come from that one less so that
is an actress called Shirley Henderson
and we are not the same human being what
did Daniel Radcliffe study history
religion and philosophy and English
literature I mean again I've got certain
problems with some of the tenses that
are being using these verbs but no I
much not won an Oscar I don't know what
that would even have been for what
Daniel Radcliffe is what what is Daniel
what is Daniel Radcliffe this is a
complicated question directive is is
mostly water and carbon what is Daniel
Radcliffe age 29 now it depends when
you're watching this I might be 30 well
I might be 31 or 32 the Internet's
forever I won't be younger than 29
though that I can guarantee what was
Daniel Radcliffe started like
surprisingly normal I think if a happy
childhood
is one where you are you know healthy
and having fun then I had already happy
childhood it was in a very different
situation than what most people are in I
think Orson Welles said working on a
sunset is like being given access to the
world's biggest toy box and that you
know that remains true what links Daniel
cliff and Viggo Mortenson does this
person think I'm Elijah Wood what was
daniel radcliffe's first movie my first
movie was a thumb called the tailor of
Panama
I played the son of Geoffrey Rush and
Jamie Lee Curtis and Pierce Brosnan is
also in that movie and he was so nice
because I must have annoyed a scart how
tall is Daniel Radcliffe in feat 5.5 I
probably go up to five six seven wearing
a little heel or some platforms by step
I mean no I have no idea I mean I think
I mean my I'd imagine work around the
ice as if you just draw two big spooky
looking eyes and you're sort of off
where that was discovered there is the
story which is true but not the whole
story where I went to the theatre with
my mom and dad one night the producer of
Harry Potter was sitting in the row in
front of us the sort of truth is a
little more boring than that in that
they had already asked me to audition by
that point at the time my mum and dad
said no to me auditioning because at the
time the deal was to be filmed to film
seven films and for them to all be
filmed in LA and they just said no
that's far too you pick a disruption to
his life and then yeah when the deal
changed to two films and set in London
and then we had that like chance meeting
with the producer at the theatre then my
parents are like oh maybe fate is trying
to tell us something how to be Daniel
Radcliffe you have to be conceived like
30 years ago and born in Queen
Charlotte's Hospital in London work on
your English accent and don't get too
tall you'd be there
thank you very much